[Music]
frida thank you for being here and i was
excited to learn i thought that you'd be
traveling a long distance to be here but
you live in los angeles now kind of
temporarily because i'm shooting i'm
prepping for a film right but it's
really hard because i i don't do the two
main things that people need to do in la
which is drive and swim
so it's cosmetic surgery with one of
them
so you wait you don't drive and you
don't swim
now you can survive without swimming
kind of here yeah i know but you can't
survive without driving you have to
drive i think i've been driven all this
while by people so it's i've kind of
taken it easy right but i've had a bad
experience actually in bombay have you
ever been to india i have i went to
jaipur about a little over a year ago
and i
uh drove around in jaipur and it's
completely insane
i was in a cab i mean i did i wasn't
doing the actual driving but it was
terrifying right it is because there's
no it sounds like it seems like there
are no rules on the road is that i mean
there are rules okay let's not say that
there are rules but no one follows them
because if you want to guess somewhere
you don't follow the rules we don't want
to say there are no rules there are
rules but you don't need to obey them no
it's just that people don't follow them
because if you want to get somewhere on
time you've you've been to india so you
know how crazy it is so i guess it's
justified why i don't drive right i'm
terrified i just haven't had a bad
experience growing up i was i was
driving and i almost killed a cyclist
and my friend had to pull the handbrake
so i don't want to be doing that to any
of your audience members well first of
all everyone here is now very great of
grateful that you don't drive but really
you were about to hit a cyclist and your
friend leaned over and pulled the hands
sitting right next to me that's a quick
thinking friend i know i know now you
had a uh uh
slumdog millionaire changed your life
right international huge mega hit
and you're overnight
you had paparazzi following you
everywhere is that not true right i mean
that is true it's kind of like the you
know the blessing and the curse you get
to choose these amazing amazing projects
that you can be part of but then you
also have it's kind of like a package
deal unfortunately and um there was just
just when uh the film came out and we
were doing press for in london i
remember being in the tube station and i
also had this kind of personal event
that took place in my life and i just
broken up with my boyfriend it was
really traumatic because the press got
to know of it and i jumped out of the
train and very happily this guy comes up
to me and says oh my god you love the
girl from slumdog and i'm like yeah
that's me and i was so happy to get
recognized the next thing he says like
oh so you are the dump dog millionaire
and i was like what because then i got
to know that one of the newspapers kind
of called me the dump dog millionaire
because apparently i dumped my boyfriend
but i guess this is a good catch phrase
you gotta admit
dumb dog they always come up with a good
one uh